I know Joey loves Gintama Joy's the only
man who's watched Gintama also is this
season four or season five of gint
Gintama didn't do be doing I hate that
they never call can we can we G is is
literally half of this list can we just
wrap it all up into one yeah gint okay
yeah we'll do the same with the tack
there's a ton of gint in this top 10
gint for me the way I view gint is a
complete Outsider and only seeing Clips
is like they're what JoJo fans were
before JoJo fans just got a little too
annoy publicly you know what I
mean you are so right Jo fans just went
a little too much with their love of
Jojo pissed off the internet whereas
gint fans have just been at the perfect
level of fandom where theyve just been
teasing the whenever you mention Gintama
bro they appear the fans they they
mention it and they they are exactly
like Jojo fans except they didn't get
too annoying and they don't have the
dick sucking meem no no no I I I think I
think it's because ginta never got to
the same level of popularity as JoJo did
it's it's the quiet like Army of fans
that just every time you say the Gin in
gint they just like someone mentioned my
favorite show so right though right they
have the exact same Vibe as pre JoJo
fans yeah I think so I think um one
thing I mean I [__] love Gintama I
grew up with this [__] um I think the
one thing I really respected about
Gintama especially while it was coming
out is that it's over right uh yeah the
manga is um or I guess he's continuing
on a different magazine or something I
don't know the saachi is a [__] troll
he he can do whatever the [__] he wants
but essentially what I loved about gint
was that it started off obviously as an
episodic comedy series um where like
each episode would have its own
self-contained Story characters would be
introduced and there' just be it was
basically a gag Monga um but then when
they but then a couple of chapters in uh
a couple of volumes in excuse me they
introduced uh like an actual story
element that was incredibly serious that
actually explored each of the characters
back stories and relationships because
there's a shitload of characters in gint
but sodachi does a really good job of
connecting all of these characters that
don't seem like they were purposefully
written to be connected like you know
when sometimes you read a story and it
just makes sense that these characters
know each other or have this
relationship and it doesn't seem like
someone has purposefully written it to
make sense I think Gintama is a great
example of that where like it's very
it's written in a way that where it
makes it so natural for you to be like
oh yeah of course these characters have
these relationships because that's just
how their characters are and I think the
fact that a show can be some of the most
funniest [__] in anime in my opinion
while at the same time giving these
incredibly heartfelt and [__] epic
like serious story elements like not
many shows can do that in my opinion
it's either what's up it's like when the
sitcom just has this serious moment out
of nowhere and because it's like a
sitcom it Just Hits 10 times harder
exactly right and I think a lot of what
a lot of manga have done is there's been
a lot of manga that have transition from
like starting off as a light comedy
series and then becoming a serious story
like Dragon Ball you hwo kutako Hitman
Reborn like those are all examples but
there are very few shows that can Teeter
back and forth between these two and it
not feel jarring and I think gint is the
only show at least that I can think of
that has been able to do that as
effective as it did um and I think
that's why it has such a hardcore fan he
does deserve to be the number four spot
I well I of course Joey would put it
there I wouldn't put it at number four
yeah it's a great show is it in your top
10 personally it's in my top 50 for
sure it's may say top on a heartfelt
rent how amazing it is he's like yeah
but it's [__] though no no no it's not
it's great I it's definitely in the top
100,000 show as much as I love this show
I can also admit that there are a couple
of like weirder episodes some story
elements that just don't really make a
whole lot of sense or were just kind of
underwhelming like some of the villains
are kind of underwhelming in my opinion
you know if I were to go into details
and stuff like that some of the jokes
can get stale as well um like a problem
with a lot of the jokes in gint is that
because it was done in sh and jum
sodachi the Creator makes a lot of
referential jokes to other Shonen Jump
series that's what scares me about gint
because and so if you don't if you
haven't read any of those or you know
nothing about like the Shonen Jump law a
lot of the jokes won't really it's it's
an anime fan fan comedy it's a shown and
jump fans comedy series what what what
I'm hearing yeah is uh this is the
Family Guy of shown and jump kind of
except it's a billion times funnier well
I like Family Guy it's not funny I like
Family Guy not funny I love Family Guys
effect on pop culture though it's funny
I just love the
memes so yeah I I love Gintama but I
think number four is just I think they
just I think the gint fans just rallied
to be like we got to get gint off
somehow okay all right okay well next up
is
uh part two we're just going to lump it
all together yeah yeah we but they they
do have the right season as the highest
rated season I agree that this was the
high point that the one where I started
checking out as I said in the
episode this
one this one with the um with the
[__] uh with the with the monkey
fight
right of course you say that monkey
fight PE to be fair that fight was I
think that entire like sequence of
episodes was probably some of the most
compelling pieces of anime I've ever
watched I think it's some of the most
compelling piece of Television I've ever
watched True it was it was such an
amazing I think if you go on the IMDb
top rated TV episodes of all time like I
think like three or four of them are all
Attack on Titan episodes from this very
season no I believe it cuz there was
like there was like four weeks TV there
was four weeks like back toback where
like this is the only thing anyone
[__] cared about yeah and and
impressive this is the season that's uh
best rated episode this is the season
that very much okay let's let's see the
top rated TV episodes of all time number
one Breaking Bad I almost like IMDb
lists more than my anime list they feel
attack Titan Attack on Titan Attack on
Titan yeah both of them from That season
in like the top five these two episodes
are [__] amazing go down go down I'm
what else is
there Titan there quite a l t in there
yeah I get I get I do get chills when I
think of that that whole fight that
happened it was just amazing and just
owin speech and everything like that oh
my God the owin speech is so good oh my
God the the Vinland Saga episode I guess
we'll get into that later it be out
there such a good episode yeah I'm I'm
I'm glad that uh I'm glad Titan episodes
on here I'm glad that anime is getting
its Hunter Hunter as well uh that's the
netro episode I believe oh God yeah oh
that was that was I'm so glad that
that's K
Sumer oh okay Demon Slayer yeah I'm
really glad the anime is getting
representation in IMD maybe maybe maybe
a bit too much little too much maybe a
little too much I don't think all of
this anime is better than every single
other TV episode of all time I I wish I
will say I'm surprised how many anime
episodes a little much now all okay a
little much all right all right let's go
back to my anime list um does it deserve
the number five
spot I think that attack on Titan does
deserve to be up in the top 10 anime
this season in particular even even with
even with all my comments uh prior on
the previous episode I'm I still think
I'd be okay with it up there yeah I
think a lot of people are going to say
that it's overrated yeah I I think that
attack I think Attack on Titan say
nothing you won't get killed I'm not
going to say anything I think Attack on
Titan is actually perfectly rated I it's
it's like it's one of those few shows
that I feel is really [__] good and
actually got the popularity it deserved
it's you it's very rare that no one gets
angry at the fact that a tack on Titan
is as popular as it it'll also like
never be in your like subconscious it'll
be a show you're like oh yeah attack on
you're like oh yeah oh yeah obviously
duh you're always it's impossible to get
out of your mind as like a as a series I
think yeah even though I said that I
kind of fell off a little bit towards
right towards the end uh I still think
the Jon was [__] amazing and it was
still very deserving of that spot yeah
it's it's one of those few shows that
hit the perfect storm of being appealing
enough to the masses and being something
like Breaking Bad where it's the
complete package things that like one
thing I always respect is when a story
seems to be planned from the get-go
which is which just feels so [__]
rare in anime where you kind of have a
cool idea and it has like cool ideas one
season and then they kind of like go
into something else Attack on Titan felt
like such a natural progression even
though the final season is so different
from the first season but it never fell
out of place and that to me is [__]
incredible and it seemed like you go
back to watch the beginning seasons and
so much was foreshadow about where this
was going to go you want to rewatch it
yeah I should I should it's one of those
shows where I think holy [__] it's so
worth rewatching because right from I
feel like I just need to binge the whole
thing the beginning right from episode
one right from season one you're like
holy [__] they're like they're like
foreshadowing season 4 and I didn't even
we didn't even know what was coming um I
think attack on is perfectly rated I
think should be higher than number five
even